this cast is amazing and so is the
script and animation chip and dale are
back unlike you've ever seen them before
we're checking out how this fun-filled
movie got made but before we dive in you
should probably subscribe to our new
channel the things animated to get all
the hidden secrets and unique theories
behind your favorite animated movies and
shows
number one
you've definitely never seen chip and
dale like this before whether they were
a stuffy or a model these chipmunks took
many forms chip rocked the old-fashioned
animated look on screen and on set it
was pretty similar only 3d since dale
underwent that cgi surgery his model was
a bit simpler in look but this was to
ensure all the high-tech tracking could
be done in order to properly animate the
character during the editing stage
number two
how did the models move around of course
these two chipmunks had to be active
considering they're the title characters
of the movie but how did they move well
they let the crew move for them attached
to long sticks the chipmunk models could
be perfectly moved around and tracked by
the cameras the same way they would have
with people number three
they always hit their marks and that's
in part because they were specially made
models placed around to help those who
were actually on set to film their
scenes
the captain putty model was looking real
sharp
number four
this movie has it all we're not kidding
puppets there's claymation stop motion
there's uncanny valley motion capture
this film truly is a celebration of all
animation at least all that they were
allowed to include from the old to new
to intellectual property outside of the
disney world
you know pixar style characters it's
cheap 2d looking tv stuff from back in
the 90s and 80s
seeing it all together is a testament to
just how far movie making has come
number five
3d models for co-stars isn't ideal
especially when they can't talk move or
look at you it's very different than
working with performers that aren't
there kiki lane interacted with plenty
of other characters in the movie but her
reality was pretty different essentially
i'm the only performer on set in place
of the animated characters she couldn't
see were all kinds of stand-ins
including a classic the green spandex
man it's very different uh just
i don't know having to trust myself as
an actor so how did she manage her
director akiva shaffer was a major help
since he very clearly explained what
would be happening how it would all look
and what to expect setting the whole
scene it made it easy for me to
settle into the fact that none of those
things were
actually there but even with all that we
have a feeling she would have liked to
really hang with those chipmunks it's
exciting to hear their voices
number six
we got the best of the new and old since
1988 no actors have taken on voicing
chip and dale since corey burton and
tres mcneal she's chip i'm chip and i'm
dale until andy sandberg and john
mullaney but just because they took on
the bulk this time didn't mean the og
crew wasn't included when they are in
their high-pitched voices it's cory
burton and trust mcneil they weren't the
only ones that came back for some fun
though when roger rabbit's on there it's
charles fleischer doing the voice who
did the original roger rabbit voice to
make the film all the more special even
animators who worked on the original
projects were included the guy who
animated roger rabbit's designs in our
movie also worked on the original roger
adam number seven
it's a process but for john mulaney it
actually wasn't too much of a stretch i
do really see myself in chip in terms of
vibes mullany knew what he was dealing
with i can be a little cold to people or
i can be a little condescending and chip
can be a little condescending to dale he
was pretty perfectly cast and opposite
longtime pal andy samberg well they
brought out something in each other
rescue rangers
number eight
how many could you find first off
you gotta thank the lawyers that is
certainly true especially since there's
pretty much a cameo at every turn in
this movie it was super important to me
to get characters from outside of the
disney universe but the work to make it
happen wasn't easy it was a huge
headache and i'm sure way more work than
almost any other movie they ever work on
well except when it was
wouldn't be cool if it was my little
pony and then we call these lawyers and
they'd be like okay here we go thanks to
all that work we get to see the likes of
roger rabbit my little pony flounder the
fish sneezy from snow white pumbaa in a
super meta moment and we can't forget
the paula abdul
number nine
these sets could make magic the vibes
and nostalgia were strong including on
these pastel colored old-fashioned
cartoony americana style sets every
detail was covered from the
old-fashioned gumball machines to the
costumes and physicality of the actors
every day was a carnival on this set
number 10
and we're not talking about the original
chip and dale rescue rangers been
working on this for a long time way back
in 2015 the magic began we started
writing this movie seven years ago so to
be here right now is
just unbelievable in 2018 it landed in
the hands of their director and then
from there well all sorts of changes
happened to land where we got some of
the words we wrote a long time ago some
of them are new we're thinking this was
definitely worth all that time
number 11
it's a big task one of the biggest
struggles that this production faced was
getting the go-ahead from the big boss
if disney was going to invest the money
into this feature they needed a sneak
peek at what was to come gave us about a
200 000 budget and a team at npc and
said why don't you make like a 20-shot
little
short that kind of shows the world and
which 20 shot short did it
we chose a scene with um seth rogen's
mocap guy they are weird
super weird
and guess what that was sent to disney
plus meaning it might make it to the
special features fingers crossed i don't
know that convinced them that it was
okay
number 12.
they do run a tight ship i was as
surprised as you are that they let us
get away with everything they let us get
away with diving into the many different
disney worlds of animation required a
whole lot of convincing and proving why
it was important to the film and just
because they were an in-house production
didn't mean disney was gonna budge
sometimes it was easier to get someone
from hasbro to say yes than it was for
disney to let us use their own thing in
the end the production team couldn't get
certain cameos but they never gave up
until they had said no so many times
they felt like they had to say yes to
something
number 13.
friends help friends make movies it's
just the right thing to do akiva shaffer
had a pretty clear vision about who he
needed to play the viking that was
actually
the one piece of casting that was in the
script and shockingly it didn't actually
take that much convincing one quick
conversation and seth rogen was there
rogan steals the show with his
performance so it was definitely worth
doing
what are you looking at honestly your
weird dead eyes
number 14.
time for a trip down memory lane i
stepped into like a time capsule oh my
gosh it's it's incredible this set had
the best of the best so it's no wonder
filming a scene inside the garage was a
special one for kiki lane definitely a
favorite was the scene where we're all
in the garage because all of that
memorabilia was actually there we're
talking all the 90s kids memorabilia you
could want from posters to models the
90s kid in me was like
well every part of filming was a joy
that was definitely a highlight of being
on this film even without co-stars
number
15. for the director this was a crash
course in movie making and i was like oh
i'll get to learn how real animation is
made while it wasn't familiar to shaffer
this kind of filming process has been
seen before it's also like
essentially the same thing as making a
marvel movie or something in terms of
production bringing chip and dale rescue
rangers to life required many of the
same processes including previz
animation and all that magic and while
schaefer had never done it before he was
up for the challenge and cut that's a
wrap folks who doesn't love a dose of
nostalgia with a brand new spin on it
the team behind it put all kinds of
heart into it and have made animation
world dreams come true we are here for
it which was your favorite cameo
included in chip and dale rescue rangers
[Music]